>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hello everyone.
Good afternoon.
I'd like to ask you to take a
seat please so that we can go
on to our next presentation.
So how is everyone?
Good, good, good.
I've been asked to take
care of one little piece
of housekeeping before we begin.
The presentations in the pavilion
are being filmed for the Library
of Congress website and
for their activities.
That young man, that handsome young
man that's sitting back there,
he's going to wave.
And he's going to appreciate
that you be mindful of that,
not bump into the risers etcetera
so he can get the best
filming possible.
So with that said, hello everyone.
My name is Laurie Montenaro.
I work Telemundo Network
here in Washington,
D.C. and could have we
have asked for a better day
for the National Book Festival.
After all that rain the past
years I think this is a great day.
I am certainly very,
very excited [Speaking
in a foreign language] I am
also very honored [Speaking
in a foreign language] to be here
today to present our guest author,
poet and journalist,
Margarita Engle.
However, I have a little secret.
There's another reason I'm excited,
because as Margarita,
I am of Cuban descent.
Not from Havana though, I'm from
Oriente, but its Cuba and her love
for books began when she
was very, very young.
She started to read
when she was young.
She started to write
since she was very young
and I think we are all
blessed with the fact
that she is sharing
her gift with us.
She has a way with words and
you all know what I mean.
But I have to say from someone who's
from the Caribbean we do
have a way with words.
Some of us we [Sound
effects] as you all know.
But seriously she does have
this wonderful gift of prose
and this has earned
her many, many words.
For example for two years now she
has won the Pura Belpret Award.
It also marks the very, very
first time that a Hispanic,
[Speaking in a foreign
language] author has received
such a distinction.
I love the fact that
she says [Applause] Yes.
I love the fact that she says, "I
want to write for young people,
not just children but teenagers
because they are the future."
I know how many distractions
they have in their lives
and it's a privilege when
they actually listen to a poem
and ask amazingly intelligent
questions and they think
about things and are aware of the
world and their surroundings."
On critic said, "She gracefully
packs a lot of information
into a spare and elegant narrative
that will make the historical moment
be as describing and accessible
to a wide range of readers."
Another said, "Engle's prose
breeds life into each character
and her rich use of
language catapults the reader
into each setting."
This is her first time at
the National Book Festival
and we hope Margarita
it is not your last.
Can I ask all of you
to please stand up?
Please let's stand
up and welcome her.
Give her a warm [Speaking in a
foreign language] Margarita Engel.
[Applause]
>> Margarita Engel:
Thank you so much.
Thank you Laurie for that
beautiful introduction.
Writing is an exploration.
No matter what I set out
to write I always discover
that I have explored some aspect
of freedom whether social,
emotional or spiritual.
I wrote my most recent novel
and verse, The Firefly Letters,
because I felt such deep
admiration for Fredrika Bremer,
a woman who is far
ahead of her time.
A courageous Swedish
women's rights advocate
who visited my ancestral
homeland of Cuba in 1851,
at a time when women simply
did not travel alone; courage
and compassion are stories that
remain relevant for all of us
at any age and in any
historical context.
With the help of Cecilia,
a young pregnant,
enslaved African born translator
Fredrika Bremer wandered all
over the countryside interviewing
slaves and freed slaves as well
as poor whites from
Spain and from Cuba.
Her diaries and letters provide
the most complete known record
of daily life on the
island at that time.
While researching this
story I became fascinated
by the relationship between
Fredrika and Cecilia.
I wondered how they might
have influenced each other
and I also imagined Elena,
a fictional upper class girl
who chaperoned life was restricted
to the indoor world
of silks and lace.
And whose future offered
nothing beyond a forced marriage
to a wealthy stranger.
Could three young women from
such different backgrounds
become friends?
For me, one of the
most intriguing aspects
of Fredrika Bremers
diary was the image
of three young women roaming
the countryside buying freedom
for fireflies that had
been captured by children
who used them as playthings.
From that point on the story
became one about changing the world
by making hopeful choices in
situations that seemed hopeless.
Because they would buy freedom
from fireflies, turn them loose
and then the children would capture
them again and then they'd have
to buy their freedom again,
and yet they didn't give up.
They kept doing this and it became
a metaphor for me of the struggle
for freedom within
their human world.
My connection to the
history of Cuba is personal.
My American father
traveled to the island
after seeing National
Geographic pictures
of my Cuban mother's hometown of
Trinidad on the south central coast.
And even though they did
no speak the same language,
they fell in love at first sight.
And since they are both artists
who have now been married
for 62 years [Applause]
they communicated
by passing sketches back and forth.
Young people will get in trouble
if they repeat this in class.
But it worked for my parents.
They were soon married and
although I was born and raised
in my father's hometown of Los
Angeles, California we spent summers
in Cuba where I developed a deep
bond with my extended family
and I also developed a lifelong
passion for tropical nature
and for the mysteries
to the islands past.
During one of our summers to
Cuba, diplomatic relations
between the island and
the U.S. broken down
and after the 1962 missile
crisis travel was forbidden.
So even though my experience was
not that of a Cuban born refugee,
I felt as if I had inherited
a surrealistic form of exile.
Life seemed like science fiction.
One day I had a huge extended family
and the next day they were as far
out of reach as if they
were on a distant planet.
I wondered about the
lives of my cousins.
I wondered what my life would
have been like if we had settled
in my mother's homeland
instead of my father's.
And even today after returning to
the island many times as an adult,
I still feel a profound
sense of wonder
about the strangeness of life.
That is why I choose
poetry as a suitable vessel
for the complex riddles of
history and the depths of emotion.
It is also why I choose
to write for young readers
who are constantly faced
with troubling situations
and difficult decisions.
I hope that the courage and
kindness of young women I wrote
about in the Firefly Letters
and of Rosa la Bayamesa
and The Surrender Tree and Juan
Francisco Manzano and the Poet Slave
of Cuba and of the people
in Tropical Secrets.
I hope that all of these
characters will serve
as an inspiration during modern
times as young people struggle
to make their own hopeful choices in
situations that might seem hopeless.
My other novels and verse for
young adults are also tributes
to this same spirit of
courage and compassion.
The Poet Slave of Cuba
tells the true story
of Juan Francisco Manzano, a child
who taught himself how to read
and became a great poet despite the
obstacles of slavery and cruelty.
The Surrender Tree is about Rosa
la Bayamesa, a wilderness nurse
who healed soldiers from both
sides during Cuba's three wars
for independence from Spain.
And then when the United
States charged
into the battle during the final
years which are known in the U.S.
as the Spanish-American war although
they are still known in Cuba
as the third war for
independence from Spain,
Rosa la Bayamesa healed
American soldiers.
She hid in caves.
She hid in jungles.
She used wild plants so again
in a situation that most
of us would have seen as
hopeless and we'd say,
"Oh I wish I could help these
wounded soldiers or these people
who are ill or suffering
from malaria
or yellow fever, you
now what can I do?"
Well she figured out
something to do.
She experimented with wild plants.
She learned how to use
what she had available
and her story is especially
amazing because in Cuba it says
if you combined the war for
independence or revolutionary war
with the civil war, because the
struggle for independence from Spain
and the struggle for freedom
from slavery coincided.
They happened at the same time.
In October of 1868 planters freed
their slaves and went to war
against Spain, declared
independence and fought side by side
with former slaves for
independence from Spain.
Rosa la Bayamesa received
her freedom at that time.
But instead of going off to the
city to enjoy her newfound freedom,
she stayed and made the
decision to help others.
And this is just so amazing to me.
I can't imagine that kind
of courage and compassion.
And so that's why I wanted to
write about these types of people,
her and Fredrika Bremer
and Juan Francisco Manzano.
I write about people that I admire.
And truly I have to say their
stories haunt me until I write
about them and then they
continue to haunt me afterwards.
I just find the profoundly
inspiring.
My third young adult novel and verse
is called Tropical Secrets and it's
about Holocaust refugees
who found a safe harbor
in Havana receiving the
kindness of strangers
when Cuban teenagers
volunteered to teach them Spanish.
Again, the kind of courage and
compassion involved in a situation
like that is hard to
imagine and yet that one is
so much more recent in history.
And these things that
seem so impossible,
how could such a thing
have occurred have occurred
within the memories
of living people.
And so I felt like I really wanted
to honor the actions that were taken
in places where Holocaust
refugees did receive the kindness
of strangers in a safe harbor.
What happened is the ships that left
Germany in the late 1930's filled
with German-Jewish refugees
were turned away from New York
and Toronto and then they
turned southward and anchored
in Havana harbor until most of
the refugees did receive asylum.
I think that the contribution
of several Latin American
countries during that period
of time is extremely complex because
I don't want to sugar coat it
and make it sound like
everybody welcomed them.
There were tragedies and there
was trauma and there was trickery
but most of the refugees did
actually become Cuban and I wanted
to write about the adjustment
that it was for them to think
that they were headed for New
York and were going to have
to learn English and then
end up in the tropics having
to learn Spanish and become Cuban.
In March of 2011 my next novel
and verse will be released.
It's called Hurricane Dancers: The
First Caribbean Pirate Shipwreck.
It's set in 1509 a much more
difficult time period to research
because so little was
written that long ago.
And that which was written was only
written from one point of view,
from the Spanish point of view
since they had the written language.
This book is about
the dramatic encounter
between peaceful Cuban Indians
on the south central coast just a
few years later became my mother's
hometown and the first Caribbean
pirate who was shipwrecked along
with his hostage, a
brutal conquistador.
During the course of the research
of this book I became a subject
of the Cuban DNA project
verifying what I had always
instinctively suspected.
My maternal DNA is Native American.
For five centuries almost
all history books have stated
with absolute certainty that
all Cuban Indians are extinct.
But the history books were wrong
and DNA studies are proving this.
Maternal DNA studies in particular
because women did survive
the near genocide
of the 1511 conquest
of Cuba by Spain.
So I wanted to write about Taino
and Siboney Indians and also
about the mixed race children
because 1509 there
were already children
who were half Spanish
and half Indian.
And the Spaniards -- Africans
were not the first slaves in Cuba.
The Spaniards enslaved the Cuban
Indians during those early years
and the mixed raced children
were known as "broken" children.
So I really wanted to write about
those survivors who did manage
in body as well as spirit
to overcome incredible odds.
Now when I research a historical
topic I try to read everything
that I can get my hands
on with fresh eyes,
asking myself whether the people
telling a story really understood
their subject or were they
merely repeating rumors.
In order to be sure that I've
researched thoroughly I use
interlibrary loan, borrowing
diaries and other older references
that are not always available
completely online yet.
I search especially for
first person accounts
because they contain
the emotional aspects
of daily life answering the question
what did it feel like at that time.
Once the research is complete
the process of writing begins.
And while research is painstaking
and meticulous poetry is expansive
and imaginative and my hope is
that the two moods will blend
offering a glimpse into the lives
of people who lived long ago.
When I write a novel and verse
I feel as if wilderness is one
of my characters, forests,
animals and this Cuban weather
that we have here today are powerful
forces in my stories and that is
because I studied agriculture and
botany along with creative writing
and I did that because I loved my
ancestors farm in Cuba so much.
It was a farm that I visited
during those childhood summers
and it has essentially become
part of my imaginary world,
sort of a magical world that I
enter whenever I write about Cuba.
I do have on picture
book for younger children
and another one coming
out in another year or so.
The one that's available
now is called Summer Birds
and its subtitled The
Butterflies of Maria Merian.
Maria Sibylla Merian and my
interest in her comes from my botany
and agriculture training.
She was a woman who
lived in the 1600's
and became an amazing illustrator,
scientist and explorer again
at a time when women
just did not travel alone
and she studied butterfly
lifecycles and proved the dystheory
of spontaneous generation
long before any of the men
who got credit for that work.
And my next picture book is about
wilderness search and rescue dogs
because in my real life in my
spare time my husband trains search
and rescue dogs to find lost hikers
in the Sahara Nevada Mountains
in California and I'm
a volunteer victim.
I hid in the forest so that the
dogs can practice finding someone.
[Laughter] Much of my writing is
actually done during those quiet
hours when I wait to be found.
[Laughter] And thank you
so much for your attention
and I would be happy to
answer any questions.
This has been a wonderful
experience.
[Applause] Yes.
>> [Inaudible background question]
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
Please come to the microphone
when you do have a question.
>> It's a great book.
I got a copy for me
and my niece you know.
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
>> But I wanted to ask you, did you
study any other books sort of --
I could tell it was sort of new leaf
for you when you went into that.
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
You know that's actually a
very interesting question
because I started to write
Summer Birds about 25 years ago
when I was still a practicing
botanist and a professor of agronomy
and at that time I did submit it
to a few places for publication
but there wasn't really in an
interest in the publishing world
for women who were far
ahead of their time.
So I brought back out from a hiding
place in a drawer in my office
and tried again many years later.
>> There's a book Girls Look
on the Rocks by Danita Atkins.
And of course you've been honored.
It's a kinship to that book I feel.
>> Margarita Engle.
Thank you.
I hope so.
>> I hope I didn't miss this
but where did you first hear
about the Holocaust
survivors that came to Cuba
because I had never heard
of that until your book.
>> Margarita Engle: You
know I'm just shocked
of how little known it is.
There's an amazing
non-fiction study for adults,
very detailed called
Tropical Diaspera by,
I'm sorry I can't remember the
first name but it's Levine.
And it's just -- it's what alerted
me to this incredible subject
that should be better
known and not just Cuba
but some other Latin American
countries also received a great many
Holocaust refugees who
had been turned away
from the U.S. and Canada.
Yes.
>> Hi. Which authors do you
turn to like mentor types.
Books that you read that inspire you
not like how to write books but ones
that help you to write better.
>> Margarita Engle: I love poetry
and I just read poetry every
day before I do anything else.
Early in the morning I grab whatever
poetry book is closest at hand
and I'll read the same
poetry books over and over.
But I really have to credit
Karen Hess' Witness as the book
that helped to give me a form
for The Poet Slave of Cuba,
the multiple voice, novel and verse.
I did get that idea
from her book Witness.
I had been trying to write about
Juan Francisco Manzano in prose
and it just never worked.
And as soon as I switched to novel
and verse form inspired by her,
I never met her, but I always try
to credit that book, it just flowed.
So I think he was kind of
reaching down pounding me
on the head and saying I was a poet.
Write about me in poetry.
>> Thank you.
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
Yes.
>> Hi. I am Jacqueline Jewels
and I met you in Seattle
at the ALJ convention
where you won --
>> Margarita Engle: Yes, thank you.
>> Sydney Taylor award
for Tropical Secrets
and while I was there I
bought Surrender Tree.
I read it on the plane ride home and
after that I read Firefly Letters
and Tropical Secrets and I
just loved all three of them.
>> Margarita Engle:
Thank you so much.
>> And I just want to thank you
for all three of those books.
>> Margarita Engle:
Thank you so much.
[Applause] And you're
question reminds me
to acknowledge the Sydney Taylor
award which is a wonderful award
for Tropical Secrets
and I do want to mention
that my personal connection to
that story is that I did say
that my father is American and
traveled to Cuba, but his --
he was born and raised in Los
Angeles but his parents came
to the U.S. from the Ukraine
as refugees from pogroms.
So I do have a personal
connection to that story as well.
>> Hi. I actually happen to be
a Cuban refugee from Trinidad
and I was wondering what's your
favorite Cuban writer or author?
>> Margarita Engle: Well you
know you and I might be cousins
because that's a small town.
Everybody I've ever met
from there is a cousin.
[Laughter] I just read Christina
Garcia's Lady Matador's Hotel
and really enjoyed it.
And for young adult books I really
enjoyed Nancy Osa's Cuba Fifteen
and I just love so
many poets and authors.
My mind is cluttering up with names
and I can't choose one,
I'm sorry but thank you.
>> Thank you for being here.
>> Were there any other reasons
you decided to write in verse?
>> Margarita Engle: I feel like for
me verse really helps me decide what
I want to write about, because I
can't fit everything on that page.
I end up with a very crowded page
and I really have to narrow my focus
down to the things that are
the most important to me,
what aspects I really want to --
and at the same time I feel like
I can put emotions in poetry --
with all the crowded page there
wouldn't be room for those emotions
in the same way in say a
non-fiction history book.
And I love to read a
non-fiction history book
but it's just not my
passion for writing.
My passion for writing
is with poetry.
Thank you.
Are you a poet?
[Applause]
>> One more thing congratulations
to you rising to this stature.
>> Margarita Engle: Thank you.
>> My wife is a first time author.
It is difficult to get published
if you're a first time author.
So what we did is we self-published
and it's coming out in September.
But the problem is how
do you get recognized?
Do you have an agent?
>> Margarita Engle: No
I do not have an agent.
I sent the Poet Slave of Cuba into
what is called the slush pile.
The slush pile is thousands and
thousands and thousands of books
that editors sift through.
And just am so grateful that an
editor's assistant pulled the book
out of the slush pile
and gave it a chance.
>> We'll try real hard.
>> Margarita Engle:
We'll try real hard.
Yes.
>> Hi I'm just wondering if your
books are distributed in Cuba and if
so what kind of reception
they've received,
especially for the
Poet Slave in Cuba.
>> Margarita Engle: No they aren't.
There would not be any format
for an American book seller
to sell books in Cuba.
The only one of my
books that is at present
in a bilingual format
is The Surrender Tree,
which is published now in a
paperback that has the entire novel
and verse in English first and
then the entire novel and verse
in Spanish in the same volume.
It's not a facing page
bilingual translation.
But I just don't think that at
present there would be a format
for American publishers to -- I
think it would violate the Trading
with the Enemies Act of 1962.
I'm guessing at that, but I just
don't think there would be a format?
Yes. Thank you so much.
You've just been a
wonderful audience.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.